j'en ai une bonne réponse là je me
demande bien qu'elle va être la la
question
est-ce que tu es prêt pour une petite
interview pardy là d'accord donc je vais
vous parler vous connaissez le principe
moi je donne les réponses et Laurent
fait les questions à Nancy
[Musique]
donc je ne la réponse Laurent 44 ans
quel est ton âge encore pendant une
semaine d'accord
vous avez compris 44 cm
quelle est la taille de ton sexe quand
tu le PLIE d'accord
avec Jean-Marie Bigard avec qui as-tu
commencé ta carrière
Thierry Ardisson avec qui finira tu
t'inquiète
farsattaque qu'elle a été ta meilleure
émission ah l'histoire d'un type qui a
perdu ses clés que raconte ton film j'ai
mis toute ma thune là dedans
qui a produit ton film alors attention
je donne la réponse les baffistes quel
mouvement va changer le monde
en fait je vais monter une secte ah je
vais créer la première secte antisecte
qui sera le mouvement bâtiment par
exemple dans cette secte il faudra dire
non pas d'argent dès que vous entendez
le mot argent faudra dire non pas
d'argent pas d'argent car ma sec ne
demandera pas d'argent
même pas pour produire ton film non pas
d'argent pas d'argent et on se
reconnaîtra dans la rue de vous
entendrez le mot argent vous direz non
pas d'argent essayez voir non pas
d'argent pas d'argent mais il faut dire
non avec la tête aussi faites-le pour
voir
ah oui c'est bien c'est bien non pas
d'argent j'en ai une bonne réponse là je
me demande bien qu'elle va être la
question le hockey sur chatte
quel est ton sport préféré
ça se voit à peine
c'est vrai que tu as perdu la moitié de
tes cheveux
et c'est vrai que ça se voit à peine et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu